Utah Utah proudly casts its votes as
follows
Feldman one Johnson to McAfee to
Peterson to
obviously if I'm not the nominee then
that's where the libertarian party goes
well I think it's a reflection of the
frustration of the party in light of
some of his stances on some particular
favorite issues of the party and there's
even some frustration with his
vice-presidential nomination I have a
very difficult time supporting someone
that wouldn't be pro-gun and would try
to take away my right to be able to
defend myself for the next president of
the United States of America governor
Gary Johnson millions of people are
going to be trying to understand what it
is to be a libertarian and it is going
to be my voice describing that to the
best of my ability and I realize I
realized the confidence that you've put
in me to me that spokesperson and I'm
very very grateful
now that said we're gonna move on to the
vice president and I understand that you
get to choose a vice president but I
just want you to know if it's not milled
I don't think we have the opportunity of
being elected president of the United
States I feel that the best thing we can
do in this point is probably to support
the libertarian nominee and he has just
requested that we support his Hispanic
which would be Bill wealth
our enemies are always those who serve
the interests of the state not
individual liberty which is why I cannot
endorse a bill well for Vice President
a better a better libertarian and a
better educated libertarian I appreciate
the advice I've received both elsewhere
and here in the last four days and I
remain open to suggestions one of those
was to read and study the party platform
which I have now done I don't want to
say anything negative about any of the
other candidates but please just look at
this objectively if it's bill wealth
there is an opportunity to actually take
the White House please please please
you know I'm a true believer you know
that I care you know that I'm fearless
you know that I will ask for your vote
that I will ask for those funds that I
will push our agenda forward
our platform platform of the Libertarian
Party is economic and fiscal
responsibility and social and personal
freedom
that that combination does not happen to
match the current approach of either the
Republican or Democratic Party of the
United States
so without waving the bloody shirt let
me just close by saying we're gonna have
a lot to talk about in the fall thank
you very much